[Music]
welcome to the northwest weekly agri
updates i'm sally baumain livestock
officer with the northwest local land
services ag advisory team
coming to you this week from the shelter
of a hayshed because it seems every
tuesday the weather is atrocious at the
minute
this week i just wanted to touch base
and talk about bloat so i'm going to get
a lot of um
inquiry and i suppose concern um
about bloat for this spring uh there
seems to be a huge amount of clover
uh in the pasture paddocks and also the
loosens really on fire at the minute and
whilst that's awesome um and i guess
sign of a cracking spring it can be
really scary from a bloat perspective uh
especially given the value of cattle at
the minute
bloat's a hard one because there's no
magic bullet to controlling bloat
unfortunately we saw bloat capsules go
off the market
a few years ago
and they've yet to return so romansen
does have a label claim for bloat uh but
you know
in a loose lick form
it really is difficult to get enough
into them but it can it can help so i
loosely that contains romance and
certainly won't do any harm but one um
they might be able to eat enough of it
to get the full dose to to claim bloat
control um
the other thing we can do if we have the
luxury of other feeds to graze for the
meantime is just hold off putting stock
on pastures until the clover and the
loosens in flour does tend to get a lot
less risky once it has flowered
so if you are in that situation it might
be worth worth holding off grazing for a
little while
um
if you're not uh introducing stock
gradually
so just allowing stock access to the
risky paddock for sort of an hour might
not even be an hour so please don't set
and forget put stock on there and really
keep an eye on them for those first few
days and see how they're going
and then also make sure the stock aren't
hungry when they go on so even stock
that have been successfully grazing a
high
legume content paddock a few hours in
the yards to do whatever and then return
to the paddock can be detrimental so
please let them fill up on on safe feeds
first
the other thing too is our pastures
can get a bit less risky uh as the day
progresses so
instead of turning stock first thing in
the morning give the plants an hour or
two to photosensitise and things like
that and
and that can help if you are in a
position where you've only got water
troughs in your paddock medicating them
with a bloat oil can be handy
unfortunately for a lot of people though
given the amount of rain we've seen
there's so much surface water about that
might not be an option
um but certainly
products that contain bloat oil can help
there's some licks and some blocks on
the market that that do contain that
product and it might be of assistance
the other thing to bear in mind is
sometimes bloat and pulpit kidney can
look the same in the end result which
unfortunately is an animal legs up in
the air and quite inflated
so five in one is not a particularly
expensive um
product to give uh so it might be worth
giving um stock a shot of that um if
they haven't had one uh in the last sort
of six to eight weeks and you are in a
high risk area
a shot might might help
and then a shot every six to eight weeks
after that
just for the pulpit kidney aspect
the custodial vaccines are really good
at everything else um but the nature of
pulpit kidney means that um even if it's
uh within the annual booster um
they they still might need a shot or
look at the product that's got the
longer the longer poppy kidney claim on
it
[Music]
as always the district vets
are on hand to answer any queries that
you have or feel free to contact the ag
team
we wish you luck
and we hope everybody's staying well and
safe at the moment and we hope we get to
see you all around the trap soon cheers
you